-That's all the time we have
for life coach.
My thanks to the great
Jerry Seinfeld.
Stick around. We'll be talking
with Jerry after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
I know you love baseball.
How are you feeling
about the return of baseball?
Are you eager
to get back to a stadium?
-Very much. Very much.
I don't know why
people always think
that I should be involved
in ownership in baseball.
Like, "Why don't you --"
you know?
And I always try
and explain to people
the absolute pinnacle
of being a fan of baseball
is a hot dog, a beer,
and a seat.
That is the top
of Mount Olympus.
Everything that you think
will make it better doesn't.
-Yeah, you're absolutely right.
-It doesn't.
Yeah, you're at the top
of Mount Olympus.
-Do you like the social aspect
of going to a game,
or do you want to just focus
on the game?
-I really like
to focus on the game.
I'm very interested in
what's going on every second.
I find it
a very complicated game.
And, you know, every pitch
changes every situation.
But there is always
the socializing,
and, you know,
people like to go.
And, yeah, but, you know,
I like eating and watching
and not talking too much.
I really like to eat a lot.
-Yeah.
-I once did a --
one of the early games I went to
after I moved back to New York
in the 2000s,
and they shot me at a game
and then put together
all the food I ate.
It was kind of embarrassing.
-That's kind of good.
I like that.
I never know what to do --
-I always have a thing
with Matthew Broderick.
Anytime Matthew goes to a game
or I go to a game,
if we don't go together,
which we do a lot,
but if we don't go together,
we always text a list
of everything that was consumed,
every item of food.